Donald Trump has been to sort of bring
jobs back to America guy fair wages
labor good for the middle class all that
stuff and he says that the products
people in the u.s. use should be made by
people with good jobs like the best jobs
even and we're going to get tough on
China it turns out that clothes made for
Ivanka Trump's clothing line are made in
a factory in China by people being paid
one dollar per hour according to the
results from an audit by the Fair Labor
Association released this week Ivanka's
fashion line is made by Chinese workers
who make about sixty two dollars per
week and are illegally forced to work
around sixty hours a week that's beot
beyond the allowable legal overtime in
China one of these workers would have to
work two and a half weeks to buy an
Ivanka Trump brand dress at one hundred
and fifty eight dollars and maybe you're
thinking hey listen that's just China
for you it's not you know this is just
one example no the average manufacturing
worker in urban China makes twice this
rate now still making $2.00 an hour's no
insane victory but the point is this is
a particularly egregious Factory even in
the context of China and the audit of
the factory discovered a total of two
dozen violations of UN labor rules
including a number of safety hazards and
the employees were not offered benefits
again in violation of Chinese law the
company who set this up has been Ivanka
Trump's exclusive supplier for the last
five years so not only is Trump's
daughter doing business with the country
that her father endlessly said he was
going to get tough on in terms of labor
in terms of manufacturing she's using a
sleazy unscrupulous factory that breaks
Chinese law as well as international law
even if I was an unethical person I
didn't care about workers rights I
didn't care about sweatshops or anything
like that if I was Donald Trump's kid I
would make damn well sure that something
like this wasn't going on even if only
for PR reasons right grant that I don't
care about the workers I still would
want if I was a vodka Trump to fix this
there's almost no one in the world right
now who's more in the public eye than
Donald Trump and his family this isn't
only immoral and hypocritical it's also
stupidity and by the way Donald Trump's
own clothing line is still made in China
to this day and you'll remember we don't
have the clip today but there was that
clip with Dave Letterman where Dave
Letterman was asking about where the
ties were made and where the suits were
made the shirts whatever and it was all
the countries that Trump said he's going
to bring jobs back from he's the guy who
sent a lot of jobs there and putting
America first or even workers first it's
just not happening folks it's uh it's
sad and low-energy that's really the
best way I can think about it today's
episode of the David Pakman show is made
possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS